- [Narrator] This is Conan and Plum.
Two very still New Caledonian geckos.
(upbeat music)
Found exclusively in the
territory of New Caledonia,
these geckos can be spotted
on the southern portion of the island.
They have been known to grow
up to 14 inches in length.
While that may not seem very big,
Conan and Plum are the
largest living species
of gecko in the world.
Typically, very calm,
they only move when absolutely necessary.
A greenish mossy pattern coats their body,
camouflaging them in
their natural habitat.
Their colors range from
a rusty red and brown
to green or gray.
Unlike most geckos, it
has claws on its toes
and these along with a
grasping pad under the tail,
help it cling to tree trunks.
The primary threat to this
species is the continued loss
and degradation of forest habitat.
This is the New Caledonian gecko.
(upbeat music)
(chiming)